des images de cartes postales des
paysages à couper le souffle
majestueux les fjords de norvège découpe
la côte ouest du pays la transformant en
une véritable dentelle de pierre avec un
terrain aussi accidenté
les traversiers sont bien souvent ici le
seul moyen de se déplacer
omniprésent ils font partie du mode de
vie
mais il en est un qui depuis quelque
temps fait beaucoup parler de lui
le mf ampère premier traversier
entièrement électrique au monde un
bateau à batterie navire ultra moderne
il fait la fierté de son capitaine il
n'y a pas de bruit pas de vibrations et
puis le mécanicien dit il il est tout
propre entrée en service au printemps
dernier le mesf ampère traverse une
vingtaine de fois par jour le majestueux
soigner fjord entre aux pédales et la
vie qu un trajet d'environ 6 km selon
son capitaine ce traversier électrique
se manoeuvrent exactement de la même
façon que les autres
la seule différence c'est que les
batteries sont rechargées chaque fois
qu'il est acquis
le processus est maintenant bien rodée
deux batteries situées sur les berges de
chaque côté accumule lentement l'énergie
du réseau électrique qui est ensuite
transféré d'un coup on navire lorsqu'il
est accosté la recharge complète prend
moins de dix minutes conçu et exploité
par la compagnie north end
le mf en père a nécessité beaucoup de
recherche et de développement
mais son patron en est convaincu non
seulement cette solution est écologique
elle sera aussi à terme économique wendy
à 26 le principal avantage est qu on
économise près d'un million de litres de
diesel chaque année dit il ce qui
représente 2500 tonnes de co2 en moins
dans l'atmosphère
hier l'entreprise norvégienne et surtout
convaincu que le transport maritime vert
représente l'avenir de l'industrie et
que la maîtrise de cette technologie lui
donne un avantage sur ses concurrents
de ce fait rude pour ce blé big n
un changement que semble en tout cas
apprécié les passagers peters meerdael
est sous le charme
sorensen
c'est silencieux ça nous permet de
vraiment apprécier la nature et de bien
voir le fjord it in surtout qu'il n'ya
pas de touax blues le principal défi de
ce genre de technologie et bien
évidemment l'autonomie des batteries
pour l'instant le mf en père est limitée
à des traversées de 6 km ou 20 minutes
ce qui est déjà beaucoup plus que bien
des traversées au canada ici jean
françois bélanger radio canada entre aux
pédales et la vie qu en en vain